alan roth a 25-year financier takes us
through teaching his elementary
school-age child to be a wise investor
east library in Boulder Colorado is the
host of this event it's about an hour
now tonight you will hear from an author
whose book just came out in March his
work is already receiving great interest
locally it was reviewed by the Colorado
Springs business journal and the
Colorado Springs Gazette nationally it
was reviewed by the New York Times a few
weeks ago for those of you who follow
reader ratings online it has the maximum
five stars on amazon.com and as if that
weren't enough Allen and his son Kevin
were interviewed on fox tv's good day
Colorado you can see that interview and
a video on the book on YouTube there now
YouTube stars they were also jointly
interviewed for NPR's marketplace
Morning Report our guest this evening is
Alan Roth author of how a second grader
beats Wall Street golden rules any
investor can learn when his son Kevin
was in kindergarten Roth set a goal of
teaching him how to build and maintain
an investment portfolio by the time he
was in second grade while it didn't
surprise him when eight-year-old Kevin
did so well what did surprise me he says
were the large advantages that a kid has
over an adult when it comes to investing
in his book Roth imparts to us some
simple lessons learned from Kevin his
chapter titles give you a sense of both
the simple elegance of the lessons as
well as some sense of how approaching
this with a child's eye view and a sense
of humor helps to keep things even the
world of Wall Street in perspective
chapter 9 is don't bet your lunch money
chapter 6 invokes a child's healthy
skepticism with the title if dad says
there's a better way I might try it but
I'm not so sure and the infamous chapter
three is and watch creamer I like
spongebob Alan s Roth is the founder of
wealth logic LLC and hourly based
financial planning and investment
advisory firm advising clients with
portfolios ranging from ten thousand
dollars 250 million dollars his
expertise is in portfolio construction
and performance benchmarking and is
frequently quoted in the financial media
he is an adjunct finance faculty member
at the University of Colorado at
Colorado Springs and at Colorado College
he also teaches behavioral finance at
the University of Denver's graduate tax
Institute Roth is a certified public
accountant and a certified financial
planner with an MBA from the prestigious
Kellogg School at Northwestern
University during the course of his
career he has held the position of
Finance Officer for multi-billion dollar
companies and has been a consultant at
McKinsey & Company he writes for the
Colorado Springs business journal and
has written articles for money magazine
his website and his book jacket point
out that despite these credentials he
claims he can still keep investing
simple please help me welcome Alan Roth
thank you very much Paula that was a
heck of a lot to live up to I'm thrilled
to be here thank you again for having me
Paula mentioned that I'm a licensed
certified public accountant I still I
don't practice anymore but I'm still
licensed so what I'm going to talk about
today is going to be feelings so a CPA
talking about feelings may get kind of
awkward so bear with me investing in the
stock market has been pure agony lately
now granted the last month the market
has come back the fastest bull market
since nineteen thirty-eight and I'm
going to try to convince you guys later
on not to forget the agony the bottom
line is if we remembered the agony in
2002 the first time our 401ks became 20
1 k's we may not have boldly invested in
the stock market like we did in 2007 so
the last 10 years the S&P 500 index is
down 26 and a half percent professional
portfolios like Bill Miller whose value
trust fund had the longest track record
of beating the S&P 500 lost thirty five
percent and 2009 has brought us more
pain although in the last month the
market is just about one percent down
right now many say that the great
depression is next in fact the same
person that said the dowels go into
forty thousand three years ago now
predicts the great depression but
somehow even though the last ten years
have brought the two of the four worst
bear markets in the history of the US
stock market all in the last ten years
a simple version of the moderate
second-grader portfolio somehow earned a
thirty-six percent gain certainly not
spectacular but beat the professionals
and beat the benchmark that Wall Street
loves to call the stock market the S&P
500 index all right now I know I'm not
supposed to give away what is this
portfolio but the basic portfolio is
simply a total US stock market fund that
owns thousands of US stocks a total
international index fund that owns
thousands of international stocks and a
total bond fund which owns all
investment grade and US government bonds
so how did this simple portfolio beat
Wall Street beat all the experts
slaughter Bill Miller the answer is
simplicity stop doing what any second
grader will tell you is a dumb thing so
we're going to go over ten of these dumb
things and then some simple golden rules
to try to prevent ourselves from doing
it dumb thing number one by second grade
Kevin had learned it's better to buy
things when they're on sale you can buy
more of it death as he would say yet we
adults if you look at the stock market
since 1996 to just recently we had more
money going into stock market mutual
funds guess when 2002 2007 at the very
height when was more money pouring out
2002 and just recently
money means too much to us adults and
that causes us to do some really dumb
things that we learn by second grade we
shouldn't do boldly go where everyone
has gone before when the market is up
and then panic and sell in times like
these we can't predict what the market
will do but we can predict human
behavior as totally irrational now the
analogy that I make in the book is macys
having a sale where they double the
price and people line up all night long
to buy then they have a half off sale
and everyone returns it as soon as I get
out of here I'm going to do some web
research to see if anyone has the domain
double the price calm I can get rich
unfortunately with the web there's no
barrier to entry and someone will come
up with triple the price calm but we
really do act dumb when it comes to
investing I used to think we couldn't
time the market but it ends up that we
are really really good timing the market
really really poorly the second dumb
thing we do is forget simple arithmetic
now if I needed heart surgery I admit I
would not go to the cheapest heart
surgeon but my heart surgeon wouldn't
need to make somebody else sick in order
to make me better when it comes to the
stock market roughly ninety percent is
professionally managed so we pay one
expert an average of two percent to try
to outsmart another expert something
that doesn't make a whole lot of sense
and later on in this presentation I'm
going to show you the odds of that game
that's a game that Kevin won't play now
if you don't believe the logic of this
this is some research that I did for a
column in the business journal and for
the book where I looked at the largest
20 mutual fund families
and then I looked at their average
morning star rating Morningstar is a
great service that ranks these mutual
funds on performance with five-star
being the best and one star being the
worst so I regressed their stated
expense ratio which is only part of the
expenses by the way there were other
hidden fees as well against their rating
and each of these dollar signs
represents one of the fun families and
just in case you didn't see a pattern i
drew a really heavy line here just in
case you didn't see the line I made the
conclusion on the top as costs increase
guess what performance decreases the
more you pay your expert the less you're
likely to get why do these funds over
here exist one word marketing
adults put too many eggs in one basket I
brought out a globe and set it on the
table I spun it around and I asked Kevin
which country will have the next hot
stock market he looked at me puzzled and
said I don't know and guess what that
was the exact right answer but we adults
were too smart we've got to put all of
our eggs in whatever country whatever
sector happens to be the hottest guess
we're more money was pouring into two
thousand six and two thousand seven in
mutual funds and what are known as
exchange-traded funds international
specifically emerging markets more
specifically India and China now are the
economies of India and China going to
grow faster than the u.s. yes is there a
human being on this planet that doesn't
already know this I don't think so i
haven't found one so we put our money
there right after it's gone up six seven
hundred percent just in time to see it
lose two thirds guess what we'll do next
take it out of there and put it into
gold or whatever does well in the next
year
now adults just follow the herd has
anyone ever opened up the newspaper and
seeing a morning star 1 star mutual fund
advertised
please let me see it if you have a
Morningstar assures me that there are
just as many one-star mutual funds as
there are five star so we open the paper
we see an ad we find a five-star mutual
fund we put our money in there and guess
what happens doesn't do so well going
forward so here's a better strategy put
your money in the alan roth global
performance chasing fun we span the
globe chasing what's hot and dumping
what's not so you don't have to we've
underperformed the market for five years
in a row our time is coming but past
performance is not indicative of future
performance at least i sure hope so the
first time that disclaimer has ever been
given with the hope that it didn't the
next thing that we do is we're so busy
trying to figure out what the market is
going to do what's going to be the next
hot market that we forget about
low-hanging fruit low-hanging fruit or
easy pickings things that we can do that
will increase our return no matter what
the market does so many clients come to
me with a lot of money in a mutual a
money market mutual fund earning nothing
or 0.19 percent at least put it in a
money market fund earning two two and a
half percent or they've got their bonds
or earning four percent but they've got
a mortgage at four and a five and a half
percent pay off the mortgage I can't do
that because my mortgage is tax
deductible well don't forget you're
paying taxes on the bonds as well credit
cards fifteen percent pay off the credit
cards expensive index funds at least
inexpensive mutual fund strategy I'm
going to show you how about a
one-percent chance of working
or hiring a separately managed account
has a one-percent chance of working but
inexpensive index fund an index fund by
the way is just a fun that owns the
entire market so the expensive index
fund has a zero percent chance of
beating the less expensive index fund
why do they exist marketing yeah
marketing advertising so pick the
low-hanging fruit next is don't lend
money to someone who can't pay you back
does that sound obvious how did we get
into this global crisis by making loans
to people that had what were they ninja
loans no no income no job who says the
US doesn't export anything we exported
all this subprime derivative garbage
globally now there was a kid in Kevin's
class we called him Randy there was no
such name in that class where he was
always borrowing things and never
returning and I asked Kevin would he
lend money to him his answer was no what
if he paid a higher rate his answer was
no Wall Street different story different
answer so what a lot of people did the
stock market was horrible last year but
a total bond index fund did its job when
the US market lost thirty-seven percent
of its value the bond index fund gained
about five point two percent it acted as
shock absorber I've had so many people
come to me with quote safe bond funds
and safe money market funds like this
Schwab yield plus fund that was built as
a safe alternative to money markets I
mean after all look how stable it was
guess what was behind all of the safe
money
triple-a rated insured subprime garbage
so never forget the role of the fixed
income portion of your portfolio if it
lost money last year it didn't do its
job another thing we do that Paula
mentioned is we bet our lunch money we
did an imaginary scenario to Kevin where
we gave him enough money to buy his
lunch and then I offered him a bet I
said there's a 75 percent chance you
could double your money and a
twenty-five percent chance you would
lose it would you take that bet well he
asked what happens if I lose I don't get
lunch he didn't make that bet us adults
on the other hand we bet money that we
needed in the next five years thinking
that the stock market isn't risky
because it gave us five years in a row
of steady returns so a lot of us adults
we bet our lunch money in the stock
market anyone ever taken one of those 43
question risk profiles and it says you
should be seventy three point two eight
nine percent in stocks you know
precision anyone believed that they
would fill that that they would come out
with the same result today if they took
that same survey as they did two years
ago the way we feel about risk is not
stable
all right now we were making fun of
kramer long before jon stewart did he
just made it more popular and I've been
told this borders on child abuse but for
ten minutes I made Kevin watch cramer's
mad money he heard the boo yas the bells
the whistles the screaming and he
thought it was a joke I tried to explain
to him that millions of investors watch
him follow him and take his advice I
think only today because he's heard me
give a few of these presentations he's
got bronchitis today he couldn't be here
that he actually believes that this is
true so adults we watch too much
financial TV now it may not be as
animated as Kramer but we'll watch CNBC
in the morning thinking that we're the
only ones watching this and we're
getting some real insights and we know
what the market is going to do in the
next two hours so again this is just for
the record we were comparing Kramer to
spongebob in the book one's a real
cartoon the other is a human cartoon and
I did make a public apology on YouTube
for that analogy of comparing spongebob
to Kramer so I did apologize to Kramer
I'm sorry to spongebob and all the
creatures in bikini bottom for that
insult and I make another apology now
there's nothing simple about taxes and
I'm not claiming that there's anything
simple about taxes but Kevin's heard me
others complain about having to pay
taxes but I told Kevin when it comes to
investing adults pay a lot of taxes
needlessly
by churning portfolios that causes taxes
by putting all of our assets exactly in
the opposite place and I'll get into
that where stocks belong versus where
bonds belong in a tax-deferred versus a
taxable portfolio so we love to complain
about taxes but we secretly love to pay
them Kevin knows not to play a game an
important game if he doesn't understand
the rules anyone ever be handed a
document like this or thicker and then
be handed a one page thing that says
you've read and completely understand
everything in this document I'm here to
tell you and these documents are often
insurance documents insurance
investments I'm here to tell you I have
never found a client that understood it
I've never found a financial planner aka
insurance agent that understood it and
sometimes I get the fun of dealing with
the legal departments of those insurance
companies and I've never found a lawyer
that understood one of those documents
so we play games that we don't
understand with our nest egg
and then finally and I'm guilty of these
this as well love to overcomplicate
things every time I violate the KISS
principle keep it simple stupid I
usually regret it the 43 fun diversified
portfolio you'll see in the book that
with 325 funds you can build a
diversified portfolio that i can
guarantee you the 43 fund portfolio will
be less diversified sophisticated market
models the stochastic ratios the best in
fundamental and technical analysis
that's completely worthless or my
favorite market newsletters mark hulbert
from Dow Jones MarketWatch did a study
he follows newsletters in 1982 if you
taken ten thousand dollars and invested
it in whatever was the hottest
newsletter of the year before do you
know how much you would have today two
cents think about how gullible people
are if I knew how to beat the market
when I write a newsletter and try to
peddle it across the country for 199
dollars a year no I'd sell it to an
institution and make billions of dollars
so we'd love to overcomplicate things
and these are dumb things that we do
that costs us dearly when it comes to
investing so what should we do rather
than just leave you with here are the
dumb things that we do and by the way
just in the last three weeks CBS
MoneyWatch as opposed to MarketWatch has
launched a new website where I'm writing
a column called the irrational investor
and it's about these dumb things that we
all do and how to guess what stop doing
them so number one never forget the
arithmetic okay
do you guys remember six months ago when
gas was at four dollars a gallon how did
you feel as you were pumping up the car
and seeing those digits add up in
lightning speed I'm a CPA so I'm really
good at describing my feelings I felt
bad really bad how's that now and by the
way what were the experts saying when
gas was at four dollars a gallon what
was it going to be by the end of the
year ten dollars a gallon and then it
fell to three dollars a gallon and the
experts said it's going to be one dollar
a gallon we're really good at predicting
the past now I pointed out in the book
even when gas was that high that i'll
bet you many of you in the audience are
paying far more and unnecessary fees
then you were for gasoline back then why
didn't it hurt so much you didn't see it
so number one you can certainly have a
low-cost portfolio that isn't
appropriate but you cannot have a
high-cost portfolio that will work in
the long run number two don't put all
your eggs in one basket own the world a
study was done not too long ago that
showed the fastest growing economies
their stock markets lagged the rest of
the world the reason everyone knew they
were the fastest growing economy is the
same reason why growth stocks the hot
stocks tend to underperform the value
stocks the beaten up stocks the ones
that warren buffett goes for who is
greedy when others are fearful and
fearful when others are greedy
about three weeks ago someone from CNBC
called me and they asked me if I watched
Kramer my answer was yes but not for
reasons you'd probably want to hear
Kramer is great at going after people's
emotions it's like Pro Wrestling without
the disclosure that it's fake so my
advice is if you watch financial TV
watch how they're trying to tug at your
emotions and such and how little data
they give you we have two sides of our
brain Jason Zweig who wrote your money
in your brain who writes for The Wall
Street Journal now says we have two
sides of a brain one is reflective and
one is reflexive the reflective is the
logical the one that says don't eat that
chocolate cake because I'm not going to
sleep and it's bad for me versus the
reflexive which is the human instinct
that worked so well the fight-or-flight
our survival mode that says chocolate
cake good some reason market going up
good everyone's else making money got to
get in mark is going down bad i'm losing
my nest egg i want to panic and cell
number four and this is really really
simple but it's far from easy and that
is don't act silly rebalancing works not
every year but in the long run it's the
only true contrarian strategy there are
a lot of contrarian strategies anyone
remember dogs of the Dow that was a
really popular strategy that if you
bought the highest paying dividend
stocks in the Dow the ones that were the
dogs you would have made a ton of money
just so much more than the market as a
whole it had a long track record of
working
once it got publicized guess what it
didn't work anymore my dad who I love
dearly and bought more copies of this
book than my voice even you know called
me and told me I'm a contrarian I'm
following the dogs of the Dow when
you're doing something that everyone is
doing are you a contrarian are you
following the fad it's easy to call
ourselves contrarians but the only true
way to be a contrarian is to rebalance
when stocks go down you have to buy some
more when stocks go up guess what you
have to sell it goes against every human
instinct
now my wife Patti who's in the audience
Kevin and I used to play board games and
we used to have different methods to see
who went first I was one of those guys
we've got to teach him a life lesson he
can't always go first I usually lost
that argument but now Kevin knew that no
matter what method we use think of a
spinner in the book he had a one-third
chance of going first I taught him some
simple math what are the odds of going
first twice in a row one-third times
one-third he could multiply 3 times 3 19
what are your odds of going first three
times in a row 1 out of 27 so a lot of
people come to me and they say why
should I go with an index fund you know
roughly a third of mutual funds beat an
index fund in any given year well I
argued far more than a third I did my
own research on this for jack bogles
book The Little Book of Common Sense
investing and I actually found that
forty-two percent of an active mutual
fund or portfolio with separately
managed to count with the two percent
expense had a forty-two percent chance
of winning but guess what do you know
anyone who just owns one mutual fund or
one portfolio for one year it's kind of
like going to Las Vegas which I love by
the way when I sit down at a table my
best chance of walking out ahead is to
do what play one hand and walk away the
longer I sit at the table and the more
hands i play simultaneously and no i'm
not a card counter the worst my odds get
so here if you have ten mutual funds a
couple us a couple international some
bonds real estate over a one-year period
you've got a twenty-five percent chance
of winning ten funds over a 25-year
period has less than a one percent
chance of winning so put it another way
people play a game with their nest egg
that they have a ninety-nine percent
chance of losing chapter six as Paula
mentioned if there's a better way am I
try it against my wife's better judgment
I tried to teach Kevin correlations
correlations meaning that if something
goes up something else may go down and I
explained to him that there are things
like precious metals and mining stocks
and real estate investment trusts
otherwise known as reads that had not
negative correlations but low
correlations with the US stock market so
that if the stock market did poorly
perhaps those funds could do well and in
the blue by the way is the first bear
market that when the first time the US
stock market lost fifty percent between
two thousand and two thousand and two
wreaths and precious metals did quite
well this bear market different story of
course what caused this bear market real
estate bubble so I didn't get Kevin
there and guess what so far he's been
right
but I'm going to be stubborn and stick
to my ways don't lend money to someone
who won't pay you back never ever forget
the purpose of the bond portfolio it is
to act as a shock absorber so many
people chased a little extra yield an
extra 50 basis points or point five
percent and ended up losing five ten
twenty have a client who came to me with
a munich california muni bond fund that
used all sorts of exotic things and this
is the safe portion of her portfolio
money that she inherited lost about
forty percent worse than the stock
market so it turns out that people with
bad credit can't afford to buy a home
who knew actually everyone knew that but
they thought a real estate can never go
down in value
with that said I do believe that we can
get a little extra yield without taking
risk when you think of it if I'm an
institution with billions of dollars to
invest and I want some risk free money
for a year let's say what do I have to
invest it in a Treasury bill bill that's
yielding about 0.5% but you and I we can
find the highest paying CDs that are
backed by the US government for up to
two hundred and fifty thousand dollars
temporarily through this year for a
taxable account and two hundred and
fifty thousand dollars permanently for
an IRA account that can be paying three
percent now three percent may not sound
like much but I'm going to urge you guys
to get real there are some people in the
room do you remember back in nineteen
eighty-one what CDs were paying about
what the 12 years I've some were as high
as fifteen percent so if the third went
to taxes you've got ten percent left
what was inflation then about thirteen
percent so you're real spending power
dropped by about three percent today if
you can get three percent on a CD you
can actually do better you get two
percent after taxes inflation is at zero
we get a positive two percent return
these are the good old days one of my
columns coming up is about CDs hitting
all-time high rates and in real terms
what matters that's exactly what's going
on
don't bet your lunch money money that
you need in the next five years has
always been too risky to put in the
market again we had five nice steady
years between 2002 and 2007 where we got
gains and each and every year and guess
what we became used to it the market has
always been risky don't pay taxes if you
don't have to this is more of a
technical discussion in the book but
where we locate assets is incredibly
important once you pick an asset
allocation let's say you want to be
sixty percent stocks forty percent bonds
where you place those assets is
incredibly important things that have
tax efficiency already like an index
stock fund belong in your taxable
account things that are taxed at the
highest rates belong in your
tax-deferred accounts that's low hanging
fruit whether the market goes up down or
sideways your return is going to be
higher
if the game is too hard to understand
I'm not going to play keep it simple the
way most people invest I say is a mental
model of a boat designed like this it's
round so if I hire more rowers we're
stronger rowers or Olympic rowers guess
what's going to happen we're going to go
in circles a lot faster paying one
expert more money to outsmart another
expert is not going to work someone else
is going to pay them more money versus
the simple portfolio that just keeps
working has nothing to do with the
efficient market hypothesis has
everything to do with simple
second-grader arithmetic must beat Wall
Street whether the market goes up
whether the market goes down every year
every month every day don't forget the
low-hanging fruit Albert Einstein said
that compounding was the most powerful
force in the universe and I'd like to
nominate inertia as the second most
powerful we just leave our counts
earning lower amounts or maybe we should
pay off the mortgage or maybe we should
do to those things but we never get
around to them pick the low-hanging
fruit and then 13
I have a lot of people come to me and
say your approach is just too simple I'm
more sophisticated well a couple of
people here but that simplicity is
fairly smart and they were a couple of
you know relatively smart people sir
isaac newton in Albert Einstein both
coincidentally lost a fortune in the
stock market
Albert Einstein took the money he won
from the nail belpre Nobel Prize and
invested in what today would be known as
junk bonds he was ahead of his time and
Sir Isaac Newton the South Seas scandal
which was something one of those bubbles
like the tulip bubbles that he lost a
fortune on so the secret to investing is
simplicity and the book goes through the
basic second-grader fund an advanced
second grader portfolio and then an
alternative which takes active and by
the way i call the CD strategy and
active strategy i have abandoned in
large part indexing when it comes to
bonds by trying to find the
highest-paying cds and then where we
locate the accounts again is incredibly
important on a tax-deferred versus a
taxable account
now this is a lot of data here but
basically the 2nd grader portfolio I'm
arguing is right for anyone an
aggressive one might be sixty percent in
US stocks thirty percent international
and ten percent in bonds that's probably
appropriate for no one in this room
maybe a second grader a moderate second
grader portfolio would be sixty percent
in the market and a conservative twenty
percent in the market and again the low
a thirty percent in the market and again
where you locate those funds is
incredibly important it it's not just
your willingness to take risk it's your
need to take risk I see a lot of people
whose objective appears to be dying the
richest person in the graveyard that's
not our goal so in the conclusion one
percent seems like a really really low
number but let me tell you every one
percent you get in additional earnings
in your portfolio means reaching your
goal about four years sooner
so with the methods in this book I'm
arguing that it's child's play to earn
an extra four percent a year more by
lowering costs by getting tax and
efficient vehicles out of your portfolio
and only buying the tax efficient
controlling your emotions even with
these low-cost broad index funds guess
what you could still get into the market
at its height and panic and sell when it
goes down and then finally the tax
location of your assets very important
so a four percent increased return can
get you sixteen years sooner to your
goal or increasing the amount that you
can spin from your portfolio at a safe
rate by about 75% nearly doubling what
you can spend Albert Einstein was right
when he said the power of compounding
was the most powerful force in the
universe
in conclusion investing is really simple
but don't ever confuse simple with easy
Kevin's already had to play the stock
market game which is a game where you
pick three stocks and see how they
perform over the next ten weeks teaches
what speculation I told Kevin he's going
to school with a note to his teacher
saying he wasn't going to play that game
my wife Patty and I discussed it guess
what he played the game but guess what
I'm thrilled to say he did really lousy
because think about it you know if you
do something like that and you do well
the outcome is going to be beating the
market is easy I'm going to go in if you
do poorly stock market investing is bad
and risky I'm not going to do it or I'll
pay an expert to do it for me either
outcome I would argue is really bad okay
so on one hand you can think of these
methods in this book is very simple but
I'm going to argue that you have to be
smart enough not to outsmart yourself
which by the way I've done many times if
you're wondering why I can describe some
of these emotions so well it's because
it's me
and remember the simple invest the
simple lessons that we've all learned by
second grade it will serve us well when
it comes to investing and my friend
Katie Carol gave me a great quote but I
love simplicity is complexity resolved
so my advice to you guys Kevin's and
fifth grade now it's too late find an
eight-year-old describe your whole
investment strategy to them and if they
don't understand it be scared thank you
very much I've really enjoyed this
presentation and we are now going to
take questions and I'm sorry to make
this so formal but if you could either
come up to the mic and ask a question or
they can bring a boom mic to you so
please ask a question sorry to make it
so formal it's a lot last time I give
this presentation there were an hour and
a half worth of questions but we didn't
have to do it this way yes Alan if you
put the safe part of your portfolio in a
total bond index fund don't you expose a
great portion of that to the foibles of
the bond market as in the the housing
bubble and subprime mortgages and take a
beating there if you're in the broad
market total bond fund great question
the total bond market fund is roughly
seventy four percent US government
backed securities so therefore it has a
zero default risk because the US
government is the one entity that's
license to print dollars can do it
legally
it's just a rumor I was not printing
dollars it was just a vicious rumor by a
competitor the other twenty-six percent
are in investment grade bonds now there
should be a little worried there because
guess what wachovia Lehman Brothers Bear
Stearns were all investment grade about
a year and a half ago so there is a
little bit of risk there are also some
other great alternatives I talked about
in the book such as Treasury
inflation-protected securities known as
tips Ginnie Mae is a great bond fund if
you can keep costs low on even of the M
stands for mortgage it is backed by the
US government and those are all bonds
that did either very very well or the
tips didn't do quite as well last year
but you're exposing very little and
again I do think that if you're willing
to do the work finding the
highest-paying CDs and it's an active
strategy because if you find a
high-paying one-year CD let's say that's
paying three and a half percent and you
don't watch your mail guess what the
bank or credit union will do a year
later they've rolled it over to whatever
rate they wanted to give you and you're
locked in at one point two percent for
another year so you do have to actively
manage that thank you
when you talk about rebalancing your
portfolio how often do you do that and
if you do it quite often doesn't that
increase your expense ratio how often
it's not a matter of time it's a matter
of how far it varies from your target so
let's say if you were going to stick to
sixty percent stocks if you got up to
let's say 65 or down to 55 that's the
time to rebalance now that's the
mathematical answer but as I've
hopefully conveyed that even a nerd like
me I'm not a mathematical animal I have
emotions and I will admit when the
market was plummeting I was rebalancing
over a slower pace now I would argue
there's not much of a cost in
rebalancing if you do it with no-load
mutual funds because there's a zero cost
to sell or buy there are ways to do it
more tax efficiently like doing it
within your tax-deferred account and I'm
also a believer and talk about in the
book it's a little more complex and I
could say here and what I call tax loss
harvesting that there are times that you
want to sell just to harvest the tax
loss to be able to use in the future but
there are ways to do it with very very
low costs
what about all these programs that you
hear about on the radio or TV the safety
net ones that guarantee you seven or
eight percent return with absolutely no
risk on the money that you've invested
wouldn't that make more sense absolutely
would make more sense if I could have
all the upside of the market without any
of the downside risk my gosh I would do
it and I would be preaching it I would
be selling it but I've looked at so many
of these prospectus a--'s and there are
always what gotchas in there the seven
percent return isn't a cash return it's
an annuity an annuitization a payment
that guess what the insurance company
controls so they can give you fifty
cents on the dollar it's an illusion
guess what do you think institutional
investors right now would go after
something that guaranteed them a seven
percent return plus a more upside i
think morgan stanley and city and bank
of america they would all be doing that
but what you're really ending up doing
is buying what i call it an indirect
investment so a lot of your money goes
to the agent that sold the product a lot
of money goes to the insurance company
their overheads the costs of the product
itself and their profits to shareholders
so what you're going to get is the
leftovers a bond like return only much
less than you could have gotten in bonds
so if you find one I'm in I've had a lot
of people show me products that they
thought earned that and I haven't found
a 1 i'll change my ways my wife says I
could never admit I'm wrong but that
would be the first
yes I know it sorry can you wait just
one second I know you don't think the
funded newsletters are very good but
what about something like Kip lungers
retirement report or consumers reports
as a monthly financial I forget the
exact title advisory newsletter are
those of much value you know I haven't
read those specifically do they
recommend individual stocks or not
specifically no they look checking about
more in trench and what to watch out for
but to avoid yeah I think most that we
put on trends are doing what i call
recency bias predicting what has
happened recently and i can't comment on
those two because although i'm a
financial planner I'm supposed to talk
whether I know about what I'm talking
about or not but I haven't seen those
two letters but if I came out with a
newsletter it would say own the whole
market asset allocation location
rebalance that would be issued number
one issue number two would be C issue
number one it would make such a boring
newsletter that even I wouldn't
subscribe thank you
so many of the pension plans nowadays
are where you invest in subcategories
and so how does one go about picking
these subcategories based on their
expense ratio with the no in fact there
are a lot of hidden fees that you don't
even see are these pension plans are
these 401 K defined contribution plans
they they're the employer funds that you
get your funds 401 K s 40 3ds 457 s it's
really an ugly part of the industry an
ugly part of an ugly industry lots of
especially small companies offer 401 KS
and the company gets it for practically
nothing and the reason why the company
gets it for practically nothing is the
funds within the 401 K are all
outrageously expensive funds so you know
they're what I do for clients is to help
them pick the least bad and let them
know when they leave that employer or if
you no longer with that employer you can
roll it over into an IRA account and
have control to find these lower costs
funds like the ones and how a
second-grader beats Wall Street so you
know I always tell people never ever
miss out on the employer match that's
free money and now employer matches are
becoming less common beyond that you
might want to consider some other
strategies such as if you qualify tax
wise to put the additional contributions
beyond the employer match into an IRA
account some I've seen are just so
outrageously expensive don't want the
client to put any money in there above
the employer match
and there are by the way many good
usually large companies tend to have
very good 401k or 403b the
not-for-profit equivalent plans and it's
the small employer that tends to have
the very expensive plans and perhaps and
by the way you don't want any comment
from me on politics because there's
rarely a person that knows less about
politics than I do but perhaps we'll
have some reform in this area going
forward
I definitely liked your concept of
simplicity so in line with the
simplicity how does the vanguard
balanced index fund and which also
rebalances by itself how does that
compare with your portfolio over the
long term fairly close I mean it will do
the rebalancing for you and you don't
have to do the mind game you can let
that force of inertia work for you I
don't use it because in the asset
location I can put the equities where
they're more tax-efficient in my taxable
accounts and the bonds and the wreaths
and the CDs by the way in my tax
deferred account so it's very very
similar some of the age based options
that Vanguard and others offer i also
think are very good unfortunately you
know it got so that some of the age
based plans got very very aggressive and
into stocks such as a 2010 fund meaning
that you would be retiring and guess
what next year way too heavily in stocks
and that forced other funds to also get
very
guess what got hit wait more heavily
than they should have than was
appropriate when we had the market
plunge last year but it's very similar I
think you can get a little more
tax-efficient but it's also it harnesses
inertia in a way that mine does not that
i actually have to physically rebalance
or get clients to rebalance speaking of
retirement would you recommend putting
new money into either a Roth or into a
traditional IRA and my understanding is
there's also going to be an opportunity
in a year or two to transfer traditional
IRA money into a Roth what are your
thoughts about that yes next question
you know I have seen so many articles
that say if you're under 50 the Roth is
better if you're over 50 you know lots
of rules of thumb and such and I can
tell you that mathematically if you are
in the same tax bracket today as you are
when you withdraw the money that it
doesn't matter one iota with that said
my answer was yes to both and that is
you know there's one school of thought
that says tax rates have to go up you
know we're printing money like it's
going out of style the deficit is
outrageous so therefore that would argue
you put money in a raw but Obama is
talking about making the first fifty
thousand dollars of income tax free that
would argue put it in a traditional so
that when you take it out you won't have
to pay any taxes on it you know the
bottom line is much like investing
predicting what Congress does with tax
rates is really impossible so again my
advice would be to do both put some
money into a Roth and some money into
into a traditional and you kind of get
some diversification against what
government may ultimately due to tax
rates
what our income might be during those
years of retirement I think we are
wrapping up I really appreciate this
thank you to the Pikes Peak Library
District c-span for being here and paula
is going to close up remember find that
second grader explain your strategy to
them thank you all very much Alan Roth
worked in corporate finance and
investment for 25 years before founding
the investment firm wealth logic LLC
he's an honorary faculty member at the
University of Colorado to find out more
visit dare to be dull dot